So if I scroll up here?
Okay, this table represents the random
variable and it's probably distribution.
Okay.
the small X
represents
the outcomes
in the random variable
the values that the random value can take
And the probability distribution as you know is a probability that X will
be equal to that certain.
value
Okay.
If you were to plot.
this
random variable
on the x-axis and it's probably
distribution of the y-axis.
And you would you know, you would get that.
You would get the bar graph.
there are
ways to describe the bar graph for example
How sharp is its peak?
That's what we call kurtosis.
or other definition is how much it deviates from the normal distribution a
normal distribution is a very
Recurring probability distribution like we don't we
are talking about probably distributions, right? But certain probability distributions
always a manifest himself. Like they always keep showing
up in different.
places in the whole universe
For example that famous bell curve has everyone knows that bell
curve, right and bell curve is observed in different
situations where the averages like
the on average like the average
is kind of concentrated in the middle and you have this Peak at the
center and they kind of tailor off towards
the end that's called the normal distribution so kurtosis.
Is a measure of how much you owe deviating from
the noble distribution is are you more flat or you're more
Sharp?
That's something we want to know when we're looking at a property distribution. Then you
have something called skewness.
Let's say you lay out your data points.
But then you notice.
that the majority of the data points
do not have high probability, but then
you get you towards the end. You have high probability.
Think of think about that analogy I give
you with the disposable income.
Okay, if you plot out all the X values.
And those X values correspond to for example to members of
the population.
Okay, and let's say you're trying to look at the probability distribution
of
or let's say you're looking at a problem where?
the random variable the values in the random variable
correspond to the number of
let's say people who buy
Super yachts.
You know, what? I see Superior is these are X these are Yachts, but
they're
incredibly big.
several dozens of people can fit into the yard
If we put the plot the random variable, you would
probably simply see something skewed towards.
let's say
the members of that sample who have hire disposable account
that skewness.
then we have
variance
from which the standard deviation is derived, by the way.
Standard deviation is a square root of variance. We'll talk
we'll get there later.
But variance will tell you how much there is
variation from the mean.
of the probability distribution
And then we have expected now expected values an
important term.
We all know what the mean is, right?
You add up the add up the data points together and
divide them by their sum.
You get to me.
but when you're talking about the mean of the random variable
specifically we call that the expected value my point is
this
all of these terms that I've talked about
their individually called moments.
Let's get into the mathematic. Let's get into the notation. So
we understand this in great detail, but my point is if you understand
moments.
You'll be able to understand the different facets of
distribution. And that means you'll be able to understand the
different properties of a graph.
Okay.
So let's use this visual representation.
to understand what the mathematics is about
the mathematical syntax about
very quickly the first moment.
By the way, the word moment has nothing to do with time again. If
you're new to this terminology, this is what I want you to
start this to remember to disassociate the word
moment what the concept of time?
now the
Is borrowed from physics?
but if you're not familiar with
the concept in physics
or statistics and probably Theory then it has
nothing to do with time.
It's just a concept now the last the first moment.
Of a probability distribution or the first moment of
a random variable.
is the mean
It's Center.
Okay, we have different ways to measure the center. We have mean median mode, but for
the most part mean is the most important.
characteristic of the center
The second moment.
Is the standard deviation some will tell these devariance but
the way you get the standard vision is that the way you get to
standard deviation is by calculating the variance?
Both of them are the second moment.
Third moment is the skewness as you can see.
Is it skewed to the left or to the right?
And of course fourth moment is the ketosis which I told you is how sharply it's
it's the peak of the curve is
and that tells you how much data has been concentrated.
Notice here we have.
a population mean
uses the Greek letter mu that's how you pronounce it and I I've
typed in the pronunciation of it.
sample mean uses X it's bar X
but it's still a
English letter
population standard deviation uses Sigma a Greek
letter sample standard deviation uses s in
English there remember this
Wouldn't we get into the formulas? If you see an English letter,
you know you talk about the sample the smaller one if you
see a Greek level you talk about the big picture population, okay?